and good morning thank you very much for
attending this press conference on the
Czech presidency after the debate which
took place in the plenary president
thank you very much and good morning uh
to all of you let me warmly welcome the
Council of the European Union president
in office Czech prime minister Peter
fiala to the European Parliament let me
also very warmly thank president Wonder
lion for joining us in Strasbourg today
and also for being with us during the
debate with an illegal and brutal war on
our continent the Czech presidency comes
at a very important time and our next
steps will be decisive for our Union's
future we must keep this is evident and
came through throughout the debate we
must keep supporting Ukraine we must
keep defending our values and the
rules-based world order and this is why
our Unity among Our member states and
among the EU institutions that we
represent is so important the the
European Unity with Ukraine and its
people will be Central to the Czech
presidency's agenda and I am confident
that it will be a success as
co-legislators we also have an
obligation to work together to deliver
on laws that will accelerate the green
and digital Transformations now it's not
the time to backtrack on our Ambitions
and we have full confidence in the Czech
presidency to do that and finally we
need to follow up on the outcomes of the
conference on the future of Europe we
can enhance the Union's capacity to act
and our citizens expect us to deliver on
this and the European Parliament has
shown has demonstrated tangibly that it
is ready to start the conversation I
will leave it at this in order for us to
have time for as many questions as
possible I will pass the floor to prime
minister Mr fiala and then commission
president Ursula from their line
yes thank you very much dear Roberta
it's a pleasure to be here in the
European Parliament we are taking over
the president's theater very difficult
time he was certainly expect from us
that they will not face lack of energy
next winter
that they will not be afraid of more
prices increases and that they will
always have enough food on the table as
you know the Czech presidency has
defined five priorities we want to focus
on managing the refugee crisis and
Ukraine's post-war recovery
energy security
strengthening Europe's defense
capabilities and cyberspace security
strategic resilience of the European
economy and finally resilience of
democratic institutions
we already started cooperation with
European Parliament three weeks ago with
the visit of the conference of the
presidents of the of the EP in Prague
after the conference I discussed
priorities with commission and Wisconsin
I am glad I could present them to the
members of the European Europe Asian
Parliament today
I plan to work with European Parliament
for the next six months
so we come out of this situation
stronger I am very much looking forward
for our cooperation
ladies and gentlemen today I had the
honor to visit Strasbourg today and
present the priorities of the Czech
presidency to the MEPS of all colors
I appreciate highly the role of the
European Parliament in reacting together
with us to the Russian aggression in
Ukraine there is a war going on people
are dying uh fighting for their right to
be one of us one of our Nations the
Russian aggression the impact of it uh
Energy prices all of that will be the
main topics of the European presidency
of the European Council and I'm a very
happy to have gone through a very Vivid
debate with the maps and we all were
basically speaking with one voice and I
experienced a lot of support
uh the first steps on our way was the
candidate's status for the Ukraine and
the European Parliament was very vocal
in expressing their support
we must now think in the longer term uh
also or on the
Ukraine post-war
we must tackle the refugee crisis the
refugee waves that's all our tasks
and this is why
this is also the slogan of our
presidency Europe as a task
and as I could see today in the European
Parliament not only the five priorities
but also our motto our slogan uh grabbed
attention and many colleagues in the
European Parliament also commented on
the slogan I believe that incorporation
with the European Parliament we will
find the best way forward I'm looking
forward for to the cooperation
the tasks in the energy area will be
very difficult uh also energy of
sovereignty sovereignty cutting on our
dependence on Russian supplies and many
steps have been done by the European
commission chaired by Madame for the
alliance we will have to
strengthen the alternative sources of
energy we will have to discuss a lot it
will not be easy but our goal is the
same technical inflation tackle uh High
Energy prices
uh also find ways how to reduce or to
mitigate the impact on our citizens in
the member states
we will try to strengthen European
Union's economy to weaken the dependence
on uncertain suppliers
we must be good again in Innovation
digitalization automation all of that is
part of the package that the Czech
presidency will try to resolve and if we
are successful in agreeing with the
European Parliament then all the member
states will benefit
and will grow the Russian aggression is
not only a physical threat not only an
economic threat it is also a threat to
our common values
they want to destabilize Europe and the
rule-based world order
and we can stop such aggression and
aggressive regime only if we strengthen
our Democratic institutions if we help
our Democratic institution to grow and
be stronger
in our Democratic
Commonwealth so to speak we have many
different views that's natural can't be
different than that
but uh
nevertheless even today
we had it again what's important is that
the European Union in the key questions
must keep its Unity
that's what will be our ambition and I
believe that the Czech presidency will
make its contribution and that in
cooperation with other institutions the
European Union will be strong after this
six months thank you
thank you so much
um Peter Mr Prime Minister of yala thank
you so much Alberta Madam president
um we have been discussing
um in the last days uh the details of
the Czech presidency congratulations
again for a very successful start we
were in little Mitchell as a college of
commissioner last Friday we went through
all the different topics in detail so
allow me today to focus on basically the
three main topics or the main mottos for
your presidency that you chose under
Europe as a task you've said rethink
rebuild repower
and indeed in repower the main focus is
to have the same direction of travel to
get rid of the dependency of Russian
fossil fuels
and over time get rid of our dependency
on fossil fuels overall
so how are we going to work on that
during the Czech presidency we have
presented the package repower EU it's
basically three pillars the first one is
diversification away from Russia
towards trustworthy reliable suppliers
we're on our way there the second is
Energy Efficiency a very powerful tool
and the third is massive investment in
renewable energy
and along with this re-power EU package
comes 300 billion euros to be invested
in the European green deal and precisely
in the renewable energy that we will
need over time so I count in your
presidency on a rapid adoption of
repower EU
for repower is of course also the second
topic fit for 55 Council has found its
position Parliament has found its
position so we're very much looking
forward better to have you in the try
logs now managing
um the completion of the files and if I
look at the very instant uh work we're
doing we are preparing for all
eventualities what gas supply from
Russia is concerned the commission will
present in two weeks an emergency plan
based on National Emergency plan plan
plans in case of a disruption of full
cutoff of Russian gas also in this topic
we are in very close cooperation
rebuild of course the topic of rebuilt
is dominated by reconstruction of
Ukraine and really for Ukraine during
this atrocious War
but we will also focus on domestic
topics and I want to take two here
um we have
created in the wake of the pandemic
recover a recovery plan Next Generation
EU for the recovery of our economy here
it's now important we have dispersed
already 100 billion euros another 700
billion years of investment under Next
Generation you are ready to be deployed
so we will work intensively on that
during the presidency
the second topic where a focus is on is
the design of fiscal rules on our
stability and growth Pact
here the challenge will be to reconcile
Financial sustainability and the obvious
investment needs that are out there and
the commission will present a proposal
right after the summer
but I do not want to miss to mention
also the digital for rebuild here we
want to conclude negotiations under your
presidency for example on the European
electronic identity on AI the European
chips act and possibly the data Act
and last but not least rethink of course
many topics are possible under rethink
but I want to mention the conference on
the future of Europe
uh you know that I will be coming
forward with my first proposals
from the conference of the future of
Europe during my state of the union
speech in mid-september so I'm very much
looking forward to work with you in this
presidency thank you
thank you let's take some questions
check television there please
thank you very much my questions
regarding uh the thing that you already
mentioned in the speech Mr Prime
Minister it's a taxonomy if the European
parliamentary votes for the veto we'll
be your next steps and that's the same
question for your modern president what
will be the next steps of the commission
thank you
thank you
just to set the scene since this vote
will take place in just over half an
hour uh so we'll we'll wait for the
outcome of that but I I want to also on
behalf of the parliament say that
regardless of the outcome of the vote
the EU needs to step up and deliver on
the energy and green transitions uh in
the long term our energy cannot be built
on fossil fuels we need to decouple
ourselves from Russian dependencies and
get our energy from our friends and not
our foes we need to get rid of energy
islands and make sure we are connected
among ourselves so this Parliament will
be steadfast in asking for us to remain
ambitious while also being realistic in
order to make sure that immediate
short-term measures do not become the
new normal in the medium term this is
not the time to backtrack on our climate
goals so I will be chairing the vote and
then we will see the results and move on
from there that's from our end
yes thank you very much
here at the European Parliament in my
speech today and in other discussions I
was having with other political groups I
had an opportunity to reiterate several
times this is a very fragile compromise
that has been achieved by the commission
that's why we would find it rather
unfortunate if the decision taken by the
European Parliament would be such that
we would have to take a step backwards
we wouldn't like to see that we think
now it's time to move forwards both in
terms of decarbonization and
de-rosification when it comes to the
European
um energy and the taxonomy that includes
nuclear energy as well as coal as a
transitory measure it's exactly the tool
that many countries need to comply with
climate targets and also to get rid of
the dependency on Russian
energy sources so I hope that members of
the European Parliament will look at
this in the same way if however the
outcome is different from what we are
hoping for we will move on and we will
take the steps necessary thank you yes
and
um indeed we have as a commission
presented our proposals you remember the
first delegated Act is on green energy
the second now this delegated act in
question is on the transition
and there are two sources of energy in
the taxonomy is the safest possible
nuclear energy and hydrogen ready
pipelines for gas infrastructure
this I am deeply convinced we will need
for the transition and we will need in
the transition as a base load so the
commission has presented now it is the
parliament to decide I've been very
clear also with Parliament and Council
if this delegated act fails there will
be no other delegated act this also is
very clear
Fernanda
Fernando Gabriel
a conference
we had a conference and misunderline you
always said that the Russians would have
to pay
they would have to pay for what they
have destroyed in Ukraine
we have figures which are extraordinary
50 billion would be needed to
reconstruct the country there are also
frozen assets Russian frozen assets to
the tune of around 300 billion 350
billion euros is it possible that that
money would be used for reconstruction
I'd like to hear from all three of you
on that if possible thank you yeah I
think it is a matter of fairness to look
into that is issue and we are working on
a legal basis
to make it possible that assets
of Russia and also partially assets of
oligarchs can contribute to the
Reconstruction of Ukraine the Lugano
conference was very successful because
it was possible to channel many
initiatives and to focus them on basic
principles for the reconstruction
now what we'll follow is the next
high-level conference organized by the
G7 presidency Germany and the commission
on convening all the outstanding Global
exports experts on reconstruction we've
never done such a reconstruction before
we need the brightest and the best on
reconstruction
and of course then to create a
governance that is comprehensive that is
accountable that is convincing for all
the different initiatives to then go
into the financing and the coupling of
investment and reforms for the
Reconstruction of Ukraine very quickly
from my end for this Parliament no
options should be off for the table uh
all illegally
possible Avenues and channels should be
looked at what is clear also for us is
that we should not allow any loopholes
from the already adopted sanctions
packages to be
abused or exploited and that is
something that we will continue to push
for and all our Ukrainian Partners after
the historic a decision of two weeks ago
to admit to Ukraine and Moldova as
candidate countries for the European
Union that was automatically leading to
the next step of reconstruction and
rebuilding this is an effort that is has
shown not only solidarity from the
ground up across all our European
countries but also on a global level and
this is where of course the role of the
Czech presidency in leading the
organization of events that brings
together the experts the political
representatives and the and the
financing needed for that in order for
us to show that we are step by step
across all the way in solidarity full
solidarity with Ukraine
foreign
part of the introduction along with Miss
Fonda line what is important is that we
must bring all the partners together
and we hope that the European Union will
play a key role in the possible
reconstruction but we also have to
cooperate with other institutions with
third parties which means countries and
international institutions which
came to
the surface at the conference also
what's important uh what the ukrainians
think what the Ukrainian friends think
how the we should go forward
as you know the possible reconstruction
of the Ukraine is one of the Czech
presidency's priorities
we are aware that the war is still going
on and there is a lot of that there is a
lot of suffering in Ukraine but if the
Reconstruction process should be
successful we must be prepared and we
must prepare today
the Lugano conference was an important
step and then there will be more steps
as Madam
Chief commission said
we are five months before the winter
before very complicated winter what a
situation with joint gas purchase for EU
thank you
so
um
are observing very closely the
deliveries of gas
um we're filling our storages that's
Point number one a week ago we were at
55 we should be a bit higher already now
we have agreed to have joint purchase
of gas other than Russian gas
and you have certainly observed our
activities the agreement with the United
States to increase the LNG that is good
um we have seen that the LNG deliveries
from the United States by now have
tripled
but also other suppliers
um have increased their LNG supplies to
the European Union or the pipeline gas
supplies so the overall energy supplies
have increased by 75 that is also uh
very good and promising
this is at the moment being the status
quo
I mentioned the investment in Renewables
I mentioned the energy saving which is
an important pillar
but if worst comes to worst
then we have to be prepared and that is
the reason why the commission is now
preparing this emergency plan
all member states have National
Emergency plans they are they have to
have them we have updated them together
but we think it is very important to
have a European overview and a
coordinated approach to a potential
complete cut-off of Russian gas
and here it is important to have two
things in mind we have to think about
where does is the gas needed most and
how can we make possible make sure that
the gas really flows to where it is
needed most and how can we protect the
consumers and our single market and this
needs a concerted action with all
different levels
together within European overview for us
is important
that we are able to show that we are
prepared for that and we will present it
as I said in in around about two weeks
in the college
um this overall European emergency plan
I think we can take one more question
yes one last question uh David please
thank you very much
Italian radio
on this uh on this emergency plan uh uh
president uh on the line
will will will this plan include two
proposal made by the Italian Prime
Minister uh already sometimes ago
based on solidarity so basically a cap
price for gas imported by Russia and a
new sure mechanism
to finance
National measure or to help government
financing National measure for a
household and companies
and if I may because the second question
to all all of you is on political
consequences
of the crisis that will come
uh don't you fear that
in the Autumn with major elections next
year
in Italy for example there will be a
sort of
g-leg Road movement around Europe that
could put in danger
the political stability of the EU thank
you very much
I think
your last comment
is it the living proof
why we have to have a coordinated
European approach to protect our
citizens
and to support the most vulnerable
citizens but also businesses
and therefore we have already
issued guidance on a toolbox
you'll remember perhaps in last fall for
example to take to tax windfall profits
to take that money to support the most
vulnerable consumers that's actually
what Italy does and many other member
states are doing that already
why are we now preparing this emergency
plan because it is for an extreme
situation where we rapidly completely
cut off of Russian gas and there we have
to be prepared and the logic is we saw
in the pandemic if I may uh recall two
years ago
um that uh the worst that can happen is
that we see 27 different National
actions you remember at the beginning of
the pandemic we had close borders uh
some member states had all of a sudden
an export ban for example on personal uh
equipment
um so this was absolutely not the way to
go
and we learned the lesson that when we
worked together as Europeans even in
this brutal pandemic we were able to
overcome it and I would say in hindsight
we overcome it in a good way but this
requires European common action
coordination and unity and the same
logic goes for the Emergency plan many
decisions have to be taken by the member
states that is good and they have their
National plans but for example if you
look at the a single Market we have to
make sure if we reduce the demand in
certain sectors or parts of the economy
it has to be in a way that it does not
hamper the overall single Market because
the single Market is the strongest asset
we have also to fight Putin's atrocious
War we need this leverage of a strong
single market and the second main pillar
is indeed solidarity solidarity means we
have a good pipeline net with network
with lot of interconnectors europe-wide
but we have to make sure that the gas or
for example oil supplies that come then
are really distributed in a way that it
serves the European common interest that
the gas goes where it is needed most
now on your question this is what the
emergency plan looks like reduction of
demand even solidarity of Supply these
elements are important
we have other tools in place you
mentioned it that we might if we needed
activate like the sure element but this
is not part of the plan the plan looks
at the energy security of supply
now the last part of your question
um the capping
G7 decided to
um
agree that we will look into potential
mechanisms for an oil price cap
this would go for a global approach that
we have an alliance of many countries
that would be willing to put a oil price
cap on Russian oil and we have leverage
to convince others who do not want to
join the alliance to make sure that they
don't circumvent
uh this potential oil price cover why am
I mentioning that because it might be
also a good platform that we have then
established
if we would need
uh under special circumstances also to
look into a gas price cap
my main message is we really have to
work together not only on a European but
on a global level
to manage the potential possibility of
exploding Energy prices and there are a
lot of intensive work is coming up to us
taking the last word on intensive work
this is something that together with the
council once proposals come to the
parliament we will ensure that we can
get them through at the right through
the right committees and in plenary as
quickly as possible as we have shown
over the past months in order to make
sure that whether it is financial
assistance whether it is us to deliver
on our legislative Duty that we do as
soon as possible and that is a
commitment that we have and we will do
all all throughout the next few months
when the proposals come to us you
mentioned political consequences I will
draw from that also The Economic
Consequences on on consumers if there's
one thing that has dominated also this
morning's debates but also yesterday's
debate which we had with the Greek Prime
Minister and the plenary was precisely
this how are we as institutions as
political Representatives as member
states ready to cushion the impact on
member states when member states have so
many different realities that for so
many years were either looked away from
or
dependent on to some extent in some
cases 100 on Russia for the supply
I say this because of course this
Economic Consequences that is going to
be felt by everybody whether they are
consumers but also whether they are
business owners whether they are
European Industries and we get a lot of
concerns about that those sectors that
should not be left behind that should be
kept in the focus of our legislative and
political work I also will then move to
the political consequences of what you
mentioned in terms of government
stability for us when we look at the
need to have governments that can
deliver that can explain decisions that
can take the difficult decisions but can
then explain them and that we feel
immediately in the European Parliament
it can affect how votes and results take
place within the plenary and it also
could take us back to what I am
particularly concerned about is that
that we could go back to the arguments
that populists talk it's the green deal
as the reason for increased prices and
increased pressure let's not forget that
the one perpetrator in this case is
Vladimir Putin the reason for Rising
food prices shortages is the Kremlin and
that is something that we should not
forget in the decisions that we take in
order for us to be able to as we did
during the pandemic as we will have to
do to take them together rather than the
Instinct would be to look inwards in
each member State and not look at the
common borders that we've worked so hard
for us to to do away with from a rights
point of view prime minister
uh
energy
sufficience
energy
autonomy is one of our priorities and
here two things come together
it is urgent to have a European
Solutions and we will break on it but we
also one are one of the European
countries who are the most at risk who
uh whose energy
security is in danger because we are
very dependent on Russian gas and
Russian oil and we are aware what it
would mean if Russia just cuts out Cuts
us off and we are also aware of how
necessary it is to progress together as
Europe and the European solidarity and
let me thank to the Europeans Commission
for the clear steps
under the leadership of Madam chairman
Madam president
in terms of alternative supplies LNG gas
and so on and as usual are rightly said
individual countries do everything they
can to be prepared for winter Czech
Republic for example has
70 percent of gas supplies in the
storage that's unprecedented for July we
are also
seeking new suppliers new LNG because we
are a landlord country which is a
disadvantage in this case
but if we don't have a common
coordination common plans how to solve
the situations then is there landlocked
countries who will suffer most
so I believe in a very quick progress we
will as president C cooperate with the
European commission with the European
Parliament and we will try to be
prepared for the worst case scenarios as
for the political consequences yes we
are facing in every member State uh
a huge social problems the people need
to be reassured because they have a
rising prices of food
fuels and inflation that is
unprecedented over the last 30 years of
course
there are concerns and we have to take
it seriously otherwise
we may fail in our battle against the
populists against the extremists in
Europe as you know six months ago we
defeated the populists and extremist
Coalition and we don't want to back go
back to that situation and this is why I
uh repeat also before the European
Parliament that the goals must be put
together climate economic Prosperity
refugees and the support of the Ukraine
which is support for ourselves and all
of that must be put in the balance and
while we have social peace
and we cannot set one one of these
things as a priority and neglect the
others this is a recipe for disaster
uh one of our big tasks as presidency is
that we need to find the right balance
in order to guide our societies through
the difficult times